I'm going to the infrastructure sector
that's our greatest need we plan to
invest in this is a conservative
estimate three hundred billion dollars
in the next few years into
infrastructure this will go into roads
into airports into the railways into
ports and I would say to anybody go into
infrastructure because the need is there
it's recognized a lot of projects have
already been prepared the government is
for example organizing mega power
projects in which all the preliminary
work will have been done by Government
of India itself and by the state
governments so as soon as you go in you
can start putting up the power plant and
we are in energy short country we are
short of a lot of power and in order to
sustain this kind of rate of growth
infrastructure is going to be the
greatest challenge here for us you know
that's one of the most interesting
phenomenon the Indian entrepreneurship
you have of course a lot of very highly
recognizable names of Indian origin
entrepreneurs in the United States
itself the head of PepsiCo is an Indian
woman in renewing the head of the new
head of Citigroup Vikram Pandit is an
indian-origin person the head of Roman
Hoss which has just been brought up as
you know as an indian-origin person Raj
Gupta these are examples really of
Indians who have come benefited from the
fine American education and have had the
opportunity but have grasped the
opportunity to rise on the Indian side
we have a number of groups which have
grown tremendously Tata's is possibly
the most well-known but also infosys
wipro the bharat forge group baba
kalyani
punj lloyd there's the in fact if you
looked at india and you look at the
companies that are now our top 20 15 of
them didn't exist 15 years ago or 20
years ago so you can see that there's a
lot of new entrepreneurs and an interest
another interesting phenomenon is that
in the family-owned businesses in india
we now have the second generation who is
coming in to take over and run these
companies most of them have had been to
business schools in the united states or
in india and they are running their
business or operations more
professionally than was the case